like nick gets tripped a lot cause like  people chirping him like the reason  people chirp is like they wanna they  want a reaction out of you and so like  they know that they're gonna get a  reaction out of him yeah but like he has  some funny ones like indian wells like  someone's like chirping him and he turns  and goes and ben stiller's like  literally right there yeah front and  center like like right behind nick yeah  and  nick's like  like what's going on they got a servant  of nick's like  do you play tennis the guy's like no and  they're like exactly you suck like do i  do i tell ben still how to act no  [Applause]  are you playing  are you good at tennis  exactly so why are you speaking i tell  you how to act no